à mayotte dans l'océan indien une
destruction aussi implacable que
symbolique du matériel de passeurs de
clandestins écrasé au bulldozer deux
jours après la découverte de seize
cordes anjouanais dans le lagon mayotte
montre sa détermination à lutter contre
l'immigration clandestine
le symbole est fort le message clair le
préfet assisté lui même à la destruction
de 16 kwassa kwassa ces embarcations
utilisées par les passeurs entre anjouan
et mayotte et 10 moteurs hors-bord
saisis par les autorités des médicaments
des cigarettes et d'autres produits de
contrebande ont aussi été broyés et
broulis hessel c'est là de faire
appliquer la loi mais la dizaine de
corps sans vie de candidats à
l'émigration clandestine repêché dans la
bon depuis le début de la semaine donne
une toute autre dimension à ces taxes
c'est un drame humain c'est ce que je
dis depuis que je suis arrivé il ya des
gens qui en profite
et que moi je ne peux que déplorer ce
qui s'est passé et rendre hommage aux
services de police de gendarmerie de la
douane de la marine nationale qui se
sont portés au secours les malheureux
dès qu'on a su que le drame s'était noué
mais c'est à dire cinq heures après le
début
car en effet ces vedettes rapides assure
frauduleusement la navette entre anjouan
et mayotte véritable eldorado mais
parfois elle mène à l'enfer et c'est
ainsi que le bras de mer qui sépare
maillot temps jean est devenu sûrement
le plus grand cimetière de la région
à la réunion les pompiers